hi guys in this video we're going to talk about
mid-back pain okay so there's a couple different
causes so if we're looking at someone from the
back the left side of the body the right side
of the body on the right side a lot of times
people have this this right up in the right
shoulder right this area right through here and
sometimes it can come right up underneath the
scapula on the right side this is all gallbladder
and liver problems okay and it's referring pain
to this area in your back and so I put a link
down in the description box if you have that
what to do for that situation okay now on the
left side of the body right here this could be
the heart and that it could also be the pancreas
so how do you determine if it's the heart of the
pancreas well if you have other signs of heart
problems primarily I'm looking at like history
of heart disease the clogged artery you don't
have the chest pain in the front part or you
might have you do a lot of exercise but you
don't sleep that a lot of times will create
a lot of pressure on the heart but if you don't
have any heart issues okay then I would look to
digestion pancreas again I put a link down below
click the link and I'll show you what to do if
it's the pancreas pancreas is on the left side
gall bladders on the right and refer pain back
up here but if it's a heart problem basically
there's a lot of nutrition things that you can
do I'll put a link down there so you can kind of
get more data on what to do but let's see it's
right in the center you have pain right in the
center for some reason the best way to get rid
of mid-back pain is to actually press on your
sternum so what you want to do is you want to
identify at the level of word is in your back
and draw a line right through the body so let's
put this picture there's an arrow right through
that person's body right here and it comes out
the front let's say right here on the sternum
what you can do is you can press in massage on
your sternum on the front part to help the back
part it works like magic but the key is getting
at the same level on the back that you are in
the front so if you're too high it won't work
if you're too low if you're right on the sweet
spot that is opposing the back pain and you really
rub in that center you will get rid of this pain
faster than anything I know now the way the other
reason you know that you're hitting the right
spot is it'll be extremely tender on the front
part so the technique is you work on opposites now
chances are you could have maybe a cracked a rib a
long time ago or felt like like a good example
for myself I've had injuries to my back I've
wrestled in college I had lots of injuries with
my upper back and I will press on my sternum on my
front part and knock out that pain just like that
but because I fractured a lot of ribs you know I
have to do it on a periodic basis because they're
scar tissue and things like that so anyway if you
have back mid-back pain go ahead apply this and
put your comments below thank you for watching